[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ihr wisst ja ich lebe im schönen
baden württemberg bin stolze partnerin
der murat kommt aus dem schwabenland aus
württemberg dürfte aber bei uns hier
einsehen und ich habe ihn auch sehr
gerne bei uns hier in baden also im
süden deutschlands ist es wirklich
wunder wunderschön wir haben immer
tolles wetter
wer mit tolles klima wir haben eine
tolle landschaft schöne natur und wir
wohnen direkt an der grenze zur pfalz
und die pfalz ist auch wirklich
wunderschön auch ich als partnerin
fahrer da gerne hin es dort und wir
machen auch gerne ausflüge dorthin und
die pfalz der etwas ganz besonderes die
hat nämlich auch ein ganz tolles klima
und dort gibt es jedes jahr den spargel
stich richtig ganz feierlich und dieses
jahr ist es zum 17 mal soweit und ich
darf den spargel stich feierlich mit dem
hartmut dort machen heißt die
spargelkönigin j mit so einer richtigen
krone
ich glaube schon die badische
spargelkönigin fährt in die pfalz und
macht den spatenstich das machen wir
jetzt heute und zudem gibt's vom falls
marketing dann noch ein preisgeld wie
hoch das ist und wofür es verwendet wird
zeige ich gleich jetzt zwar erst mal
schön in die pfalz rüber
[Musik]
jetzt immer hier in mutterstadt
angekommen in der wunderschön unfalls
ist auch wirklich nur ein katzensprung
von uns entfernt man sagt man so schön
die pfalz ist die toskana deutschlands
denn hier gibt es den besten wein den
westen spargel
hier gibt es ganz viel frisches obst und
gemüse und heute wenn ich ein hartmut
besuchen hier auf dem spargelfeld er
wird mir zum einen zeigen was das
besondere am spargel ist was die
unterschiede zwischen grün und weiß sind
wie man den spargel perfekt verarbeitet
und ich möchte ihnen momentan auch mal
fragen wie es ihm denn so geht denn die
landwirte sind hat wirklich immer die
leidtragenden die müssen sich praktisch
und anfang des jahres überlegen was
kommt denn dieses jahr schon wieder auf
uns zu
eine hitzewelle schädlinge ernteausfall
haben die pflanzen genügend wasser aber
die landwirte sind halt wirklich
diejenigen jeden tag für euch auf dem
feld stehen mit ihrem team die
erntehelfer brauchen und die einfach
dastehen und dafür sorgen dass wir
frisches obst und gemüse aus der region
haben ohne flugwege pestizidfrei
schadstofffrei und deswegen finde ich
sollte immer die landräte auf jeden fall
unterstützen da hinten steht schon da
hartmut mit seinem sohn und dem besuch
ich jetzt und dann lernen wir etwas über
spargeln und können schauen was wir als
konsumenten für die landwirte vertun
können
[Musik]
alle warten muss also sehr schön heute
da ein bisschen was über dem spargel zu
erfahren wie man spargel sticht und also
wird dieses als erklärung spargel sagt
man jemandem anstich die spargel die
sprachwurzel selbst wird er mit dem
schönen titel zur bedeckt dass man
schöne lange stange hat und dass man die
dann natürlich dann nicht komplett
ausbuddeln muss hat man immer die langen
messer inzwischen hat man sie hier mit
einer v förmigen kerbe von daran dass
man auch schön an den spargel dann rein
stechen kann ja uns gut abgeschnitten
wird machen sich legen nur ein teil
ausgraben gucken wo der spargel ist
dagegen ein messer ohne reihen und mit
den sack mit einem guten start kann man
es eben abschneiden also kann ich mir
die spargelpflanze so vorstellen das
sind nicht einzelne stängel wie so eine
blume die erwachsenen sondern eine große
pflanze unter der erde und da wächst
dann immer wieder der frische spargel
kann ist ungefähr so viel wie nach und
man hat auch nur um die wurzeln in der
mitten in der knospe es dann immer
wieder eine stange nach der anderen
das sind dann eben auch die typische wo
man bei der spargel sagt es sollte ein
geübter enders sein dass er nicht bei
menden von einer stange an die stange
nebendran im essen ritz reinmacht die
dann halt ja nicht mehr so schön
aussieht teilweise dann irgendwann
wieder verworfen wird entsorgt werden
also eine ausgewachsene spargelpflanze
die hat schon so in schubkarren voll
machen mit der wurzel also das sieht man
irgendwas dann achte den ganzen dampf in
der breite her wie man heute mit der
maschinen schön breit machen kann
es kommt überall irgendwie noch nicht
wieder raus wir können mal vorne dran
gehen dann wird das man direkt an herrn
act und darf schon noch gern mal
probieren ja also das sehe ich schon den
ersten spargel kopf richtig das sind die
sachen wo man jetzt heute natürlich
machen sagt david plastik im feld das
hat nichts damit zu tun dass wir die
spanier nur einmal am tag enden müssen
manchmal so schön nach der riesige guckt
dem feld wo ich so eine spitze die unter
der erde anfängt zu schieben
heute macht das ist einfach wir sind ja
auch faul mehr sagen wir gucken da wurde
spare ich direkt steht geht man dann
immer mit dem finger sagt man so schön
die zwei finger technikum an der stange
reinmacht eine coole dass man sehen kann
wo die spargelstangen im darm nach unten
geht
dann nehme ich jetzt mal ein messer und
für sitze an der stange nach unten an
möglichst senkrecht dass ich mit kiefer
kommen ja halte dann die spargelfest und
dann stehe ich einmal tief rein zweites
mal und dann habe ich hier die stange
schöne in der hand aber du kannst ja
gerne aber selbst probiert ich probiere
ich sehe es ja schon drei spargelstange
die einiges schief aber ich probiere
meinen westen entlang runder und nur in
die kur nachhinein weg und trotzdem ein
schieber ja immer nach stechen sehr gut
sagt meine erste spargelstange nicht
gerade aber schön radarkontrolle prima
spargel kann man fast sagen zwischen
fünf und sechs zentimeter wächst eine am
tag bewegen kann man schon gucken wenn
man beim ernten irgendwo eine kleinere
sieht sich das trainiert sind die müssen
wir jetzt einfach mit rausnehmen weil
die mannschaft hinten dran nochmal die
nächste die renten möchtest okay das
nicht so einfach aussieht
ich erinnere mich an ein spargel stechen
in österreich aber ich habe es immer so
anstrengend in erinnerung da prima
jedoch gut auf
und er erntet praktisch einmal am tag
spur gekommen dann nach hause bei uns
werden dann auch in eiswasser schnell
heruntergekühlt werden die beste
qualität ist hier dünner keller die kann
ich einfach nehmen und dann die erde
wieder das ist jetzt wieder meinen
transportieren ist hafenbecken
man macht ihr einfach die coole wieder
zu dass die nächsten stangen dann wieder
schöne mit erde bedeckt sind und dabei
immer richtig frisch was morgens
geändert wird wird schon am gleichen tag
auf dem spargelhof im ladenverkauf gab
ja ich war gekommen heimkommen in die
kühlung weil wir die beste qualität
erhalten
deswegen kommen sondern auf die
waschmaschine und saubergemacht worden
war
die spitze hat rouse geguckt kann es zu
lange braucht ja kaputt ist
die leute beim spargelstechen helfen
wolle und nichts bringen aber wir können
sagen es war super schöne stange dies
absolut gerade dies gut akteure die ist
lang genug also macht sie nicht so
schlecht dass alles ab was noch das
beste stück natürlich als cache
vielleicht ein bisserl navarro spargel
sind auch sehr gut also als rohkostsalat
kann man sich mit rheinischem krieg
später rohkostsalat etwa ein paar
spargel fürs team bringen die spanier
mit nach hause und dann wieder dahin
zubereitet ich mag es sehr schlecht
kommt ein man bitteschön es darf jeder
hier schauer
ihr habt 202 einstreichen richtig starke
spitze abgetragen
ich stecke ihn trotzdem raus so war etwa
der ich zum spielerische mittel aufgabe
dass die starke sich wohl nun
herauskommt so und dann nicht so nah an
der stange einfach diesen abstand so und
jetzt das messer herum haben heute
starke vorne welchem druck das internet
ist heute schon noch einige probieren
wollen wir weiter dass er lang genug ist
spanier umdrehen und ab noch mal nach
stechen ständig wie nie eintritt ist ja
also ich glaube es braucht nur auf
diesen schulungen dorf wissen was wird
sollte das ist jetzt auch novelle
ausfälle ernteausfälle
das ist alles nichts gegen murat auf dem
feld der matrix ganze feld kaputt die
haben wir gut genug ablaufen wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist das ziel alle dass es eine pumpe
damit kann man wasser aus dem boden
pumpen
da stellt man einfach hier so einen
traktor hin und dann noch eine zapfwelle
hinten dran heute dort kranken oder
traktor sowas dann praktisch schaltet
man das dann halt an
dann drehte sich schnell dann kommt er
aus dem boden das grundwasser geht dann
dahin draußen wie man hier die rohre
sieht das ist nett verbunden
aber da hinten spritzt
ok
jetzt aber nicht nur leckeren frischen
spargel aus der pfalz sondern auch noch
vom falls marketing 200.000 euro
bekommen für unsere stiftung als spende
vielen dank da freuen sich die kinder
und familien
ja gibt es eine neue kindergarten küche
also denkt daran jeder spargel und der
bei euch auf dem teller liegt dafür hat
man sich einmal gewirkt in spargel
gestochen ist denn spargel wirklich sehr
bewusst ich habe heute vielleicht
bisserl was dazu beigetragen abhang
krank bist aber man sieht was es für
eine arbeit ist mit dem tage man sieht
genau so dass man natürlich dann auch
irgendwo später auf dem teller oder beim
einkauf achten sollte das aus der region
ist und der regionalen bauern mit zu
unterstützen
die beste qualität bekommt man eben wenn
man es jetzt gerade was geändert hat und
dann mittags gleich mit nach hause
nehmen kann
die wird dann natürlich mit teilnehmen
wollen und direkt mal probieren können
das passt dem machen wir jetzt erfahren
zu hause also seid gespannt waren wieder
nach waghäusel und bereiten leckeren
spargel tour
[Musik]
und jeder regional landwirt hat ja auch
normalerweise einen hofladen dort könnt
ihr euch die erzeugnisse meist sogar die
ganze woche kaufen so unterstützt der
die menschen und die region und ihr habt
zudem noch die beste qualität und das
ganze tagesfrisch frischer spargel vom
feld einmal habe ich sie passieren den
ganz normalen weißen spargel und dann
habe ich noch suppen spargel mitgenommen
der ist nämlich schön dünn und ein
qualitätsmerkmal von frischem spargel
ist ich mein weniger ist bei eurem land
wird vor ort kauft müsste das nicht
machen aber hier wenn die stangen
aneinander reiht
dann quietschen die also suppen spargel
ist ganz dünn denn der muss hier oben
gar nicht geschält werden sondern
wirklich nur hier unten und die spargel
vom bauern vor ort die sind einfach so
frisch dass ihr nicht diese trockenen
enden unten habt am besten ist es auch
immer er verarbeitete ihnen direkt am
gleichen tag so habt ihr die volle
frische das volle aroma wenn ihr aber
sagt ich möchte jetzt auch spargel
kaufen für morgen und übermorgen
vielleicht dann könnt ihr ihn einfach in
ein feuchtes tuch entwickeln und im
kühlschrank lagern
man kann ihn sogar einfrieren da können
schon mal schälen und zum beispiel ein
vakuum mailen oder einfach im
gefrierbeutel geben einfrieren und dann
habt ihr auch im winter was davon denn
die spargel sorgt leider nur bis mitte
ende juni
man sagt auch stich den spargel nicht
nachdem johann i also nachdem johannes
tag im juni wieder nicht mehr gesprochen
weil dann einfach die spargelpflanze
wachsen darf um eben dann auch
nährstoffe für das fürs nächste jahr zu
haben dass im nächsten leben auch die
ernte gut ist ja so viel eigentlich zum
spargel
ich werde jetzt hier gleich zum einen
spargel ganz normal zu bereiten
ich habe jetzt nur den weißen
mitgenommen und dann eben auch mal eine
spargelsuppe machen die machen wir
gleich im anschluss zuerst einmal zeige
ich euch jetzt wie man diese sprache
verarbeitet also da ist wirklich wichtig
wenn sie frisch sind dann muss man hier
unten fast gar nichts wegschneiden nur
ein bis zwei zentimeter und den spargel
natürlich schicken
grüner spargel da muss gar nicht
geschält werden denn da ist einfach ganz
knackig und ganz frisch und man kann
spargel roh essen gebraten gekocht
gebacken
in der pfanne zubereitet und das ist
wirklich alles geschmackssache
ich werde jetzt hier gleich dampfgaren
im backofen in meinem dampfgarer und
dazu eine hollandaise machen dass
hollande einmal die klassische version
und einmal gleich die vegane version am
besten nehmt euch jetzt einfach im
spargelschäler viele hofläden bieten
aber auch geschälten spargel anderes
magazin gehen sich den spargel aussuchen
und direkt stehlen lassen so machen wir
das auch meistens und dann lass dir hier
oben den kopf weg den muss man nicht
schälen setzt den schiller an und stellt
die schale weg und die habe ich dann
gleich noch auf denn die könnt ihr
wirklich super noch benutzen um noch
mehr geschmack in eure sprache zurück zu
bekommen könnt ihr noch einfach flach
hinlegen
spargel gehört wirklich zu meinen
lieblingsspeisen gerade jetzt so im
frühjahr sommer zum einen weil er mir
sehr gut schmeckt und zum anderen weil
er gesund ist vitaminreich ist und pro
100 gramm nur 20 kalorien hat es
wirklich wie ein fitness essen wenn man
nicht gerade die sauce hollandaise dazu
ist aber ich mag spargel ganz gerne auch
im salat oder als suppe oder vom grill
und da braucht man dann auch echt nicht
viel dazu und man erkennt den murat
murat ist ja wirklich so der
fleischesser schlechthin und ich kriege
es auch selten aus ihm raus sagt okay
heute mal kein fleisch aber wenn es bei
uns spargel gibt dann verzichtet er auch
gerne auf leihspieler sagt okay spargel
ist für ihn sowieso eine art
fleischersatz und man rechnet so
ungefähr 500 gramm spargel pro person
wenn nicht sogar bis zu einem kilo für
gute esser und je nach dem eben was ihr
noch als beilage oder als vorspeise habt
könnt ihr wirklich so einiges an spargel
rechnen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier noch kartoffeln
geschält und werde jetzt an ihr dem
spargel und die kartoffel und dampfgaren
ihr könnt aber auch den spargel ganz
einfach im topf kochen mit etwas wasser
eine prise salz und zucker dazu und dann
ist es wirklich eine geschmackssache
mögt ihr ihn etwas weicher oder mögt ihr
ihnen etwas bis fester es gibt auch
extra spargelköpfe einfach der spargel
so drin gegart wird da ist dann also der
wert unserer hochkant reingestellt und
der topf ist in etwa so hoch
dann füllt er ihnen etwas so weit mit
wasser das kocht haben und der kopf des
spargels der wird dann praktisch dampf
gegart und der ist ja immer schneller
durch als hier unten und daher wird dann
einfach nicht matschig werden wie gesagt
dampfbahn in einem backofen nehme ich
aber den spargel raus weil die kartoffel
nicht länger brauchen
ich halte die jetzt noch schiebt schon
mal die kartoffel im backofen
und dann kommt der spargel gleich dazu
hast ein geschenk für mich was ist das
ich mache es auch sofort moment also die
kommission backofen
[Musik]
ja ich hab noch was drin
knapp 20 minuten und dann kommt der
spargel vielleicht dazu mein gott ist
das herz für mich
danke die beste was das kommt jetzt
ich muss gleich darf ich in so eine
pflanze dann rein machen
okay in die küche drüben ich mache es
jetzt mal kurz in die vase hier und
später hat sich die pflanze ok danke
oh mein gott
weißt du eigentlich dass du so süß bis
mitwirken
barilla eine sauce hollandaise müsst ihr
wissen ist keine leichte source also
nicht im sinne von es ist schwer zu
machen sondern ich schalte business also
eine emulsion aus eigelb und butter also
wundert euch jetzt nicht ich habe sie
nicht erfunden
das waren die franzosen und ich mache
jetzt nur nach dafür braucht ihr aber
construction meine handschrift oder
joschi sofort der ist sollte eigentlich
so ist alles sehr heißen denn ich liebe
mutter ihr braucht dafür 250 gramm
butter 3 etwas zitronensaft oder zum
beispiel auch weißweinessig oder auch im
schuss weißwein salz und pfeffer das
war's mehr brauchte nicht die butter
wird erwärmt
aber nicht heiß sondern wirklich nur
handwarm ihr könnt hier auch
butterschmalz nehmen das ist nämlich
dann schon geklärte butter
ich hätte jetzt hier in diesem gefäß
damit ich sie später gut aus gießen kann
ich werde jetzt so lange ich hier schon
mal wasser kochen
ich mache jetzt hier ganz klassisch auf
dem wasserbad ihr könnt aber auch eure
küchenmaschine nehmen erkennen gut zum
beispiel oder bei der kitchenaid gibt es
ja auch die schüssel mit präziser
temperatureinstellung hier kann ich
jetzt schon mal das wasserbad erwärmen
also das wasser drin kochen und die
eigelbe in die schüssel geben und da
brauchte jetzt eine temperatur feste
glasschüssel oder auch eine
metallschüssel ich gebe die eigene will
hier in die rührschüssel ich kann auch
schon direkt für drohnen saft dazu geben
wie gesagt weißweinessig könnte auch
nehmen und noch ein bisschen weißwein
also so business teure braucht ihr auf
jeden fall salz und pfeffer
und jetzt einen stabmixer und auf dem
wasserbad erwärmen
[Musik]
dachte jetzt darauf dass das wasser
marsch also das wasser die schüssel
nicht berührt und erwärmt sitzt hier
ich nehme doch meinen schneebesen
aufsatz
ich wollte meinen schneebesen trotzdem
habe ich gedacht na komm ich dem
stabmixer dem schneebesen weil die menge
ist einfach zu klein für schon stabmixer
nicht immer schön rühren damit kein
rührei ihm steht und wenn ihr das jetzt
in der küchenmaschine macht mit hitze
funktion einfach zu 48 grad erwärmen
schön weiß cremig rühren
[Musik]
sobald ihr ein geld mache dann cremig
ist kommt jetzt die programme dazu und
im ganzen strahl wie bei mayonnaise
sozusagen damit sie nicht gerinnt und
das geld das fett schön aufnehmen also
wirklich ganz ganz langsam sei geld wird
dann auch gleich dickflüssiger ich muss
echt sagen privat mache ich nur in der
küchenmaschine in der kenwood da muss
ich nämlich nicht am herd stehen und
rühren die so mach ich es so gemacht und
total irgendwie so ne mal schauen sie
wir dass das nicht jeder sagt man
braucht für immer alles immer ja so kann
man sich auch mal etwas umständlich
ausgehen die eu ständig aber muss halt
dran stehen
guckt mal eine perfekte sauce
hollandaise etwas woran merkst du dass
dieser schönen kommen so dickflüssig
nicht gewonnen so ich es nicht legal
normale ist die normale und ich habe mir
jetzt als tipp abgeguckt in der
gastronomie beim jamie oliver hab ich
mir das abgas kohl die füllen jetzt die
soße weil die muss man eigentlich sofort
verzehrt und die schutzbereiche muss
sofort verzerren und die führen ihre
soße in thermoskannen ab richtig cool
weil da kann also einfach bis zu zwei
stunden aufbewahren für seine gäste und
ich hab mir jetzt gedacht ich hab keine
thermoskanne und thermoskanne auf dem
tisch jetzt nicht so schön
ich habe jetzt hier meinen gusseisernen
topf genommen den mini achtung heißes
wasser rein weil damit der warm ist
jetzt ist der topf war
jetzt ist der topf schütte das wasser
weg ach so du wirst du in der heißen
torfrau ganz gehen
hier bin ich auf den backofen rein
stellen können nein dann wird er nämlich
zu heiß das ding ist hat dies jetzt
schön warm aber bis jetzt mein spargel
fertig ist auf dem tisch ist ist sie
einfach zu kalt also fühle ich das jetzt
hier rein
[Musik]
also die halte ich jetzt kurz war und
zeigt euch jetzt noch wie man die
wegnahme version macht die kartoffeln
sind vor gedämpft zu spargel kommt dazu
wir mögen ihn eher al dente also nicht
so lange dämpfen
[Musik]
für die vegane version nämlich 100 gramm
veganer butter 50 gramm mehl etwas
kurkuma für die farbe gemüsebrühe senf
vegane sahne salz und pfeffer wenn ihr
diese soße etwas fettreduzierter machen
wollt könnt ihr auch einfach nur 40
gramm butter nehmen ich habe es jetzt
mit rein weil ich einfach auch diese
cremige konsistenz haben möchte ich
hätte es auch geschmacksträger vegane
butter jetzt vielleicht nicht so
unbedingt aber fest im allgemeinen schon
jetzt schön hier schmelzen
im prinzip ist es eine schamlose veganen
ein bisschen anders aufgepumpt ja das
war schön die butter zerlassen
ich brate dass medien zu etwa eine
minute mit an
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt die gemüsebrühe rein
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr auch hier
gerne ein bisschen weit rein dazu geben
oder für eine leichte säure auch um
weißweinessig oder spritzer zitronensaft
dann die veganer sahne kurkuma für die
farbe natürlich da das eigelb ist hier
fährt und mit salz und pfeffer
abschmecken den senf gebe ich erst zum
schluss dazu denn der verliert einfach
seinen geschmack durch das erwärmen und
jetzt lasse ich die sauce aufkochen
leicht eindecken und dann ist sie fertig
und die kann man dann auch ganz gut
aufheben
die könnte auch gerne noch am nächsten
tag erwerben und ärzte
[Musik]
jetzt richten
die spargelspitzen oben ist immer das
highlight okay jetzt auch mal lecker
lecker und ich habe ihnen sogar nur fünf
minuten gedünstet der nicht mag spargel
wenn er so ein bisschen bis heute bei
mega lecker als assistent des super
gelingen sicher wenn ihr die tipps
beachtet wie gesagt nicht überhitzen und
einfach sofort servieren nächste schon
vor stück halt denn wir haben
zwischendurch fotos gemacht daher stand
selbst 15 minuten aber ansonsten wie
gesagt einfach schön im köpfchen warm
halten oder in sonnen in so einer
thermoskanne eberhard roth ganz ganz
liebe grüße richtig lecker das schade
das ist jetzt nicht da wo ich gerade in
der zeit erste erwin anders aber ich
ganz ganz toll ganz toller spargel
ich will jetzt noch und vegan ist das
was für dich wohl km h probier mal gut
wir hatten sie vorgestern schon da ist
es ja schon probleme bevor
trotzdem blickte ich lieb' schlagen so
freshen man merkt wirklich dass es
frisch gestochener spargel ist weil er
wirklich so so knackig ist so einfach
sohn bis noch als cool
durch die lücke perfekt ich wollte jetzt
eigentlich noch die suppe machen aber
ich glaube es sprengt einfach den rahmen
des videos deswegen werde ich es super
für uns morgen zubereiten paket sind
spargel schön 1 inso ein feuchtes
küchentuch kommt es im kühlschrank
morgen gibt's bei uns die suppe dazu
morgen mittag man sich auch vegan für
euch und normal für uns mit butter hat
der geschmacksträger schlechte und
butter schmeckt anders
ich hoffe ich habe das video gefallen
und vielleicht habt ihr das ein oder
andere über spargel dazu gelernt wie
gesagt meine message in diesem video ist
einfach kauft den spargel bei euch vor
ort von euren bauern von eurem
landwirten unterstützt eure region da
bekommen sie zum einen die beste
qualität und die unterstützt die
menschen die dort arbeiten
bis zum nächsten mal jessie j
[Musik]